Bonjour!
Bonjour, mes ami!
I am for a ravine!
I am a ravine for...
Tic-tac-tac-e-m-bapé!
Bonjour, bonjour!
Hello, hello!
I am French, tomato!
Hello,
hello, everybody.
No!
She's French!
And she's my bell, a donkey bird.
She has to forget.
Guys, guys.
Guys.
have to cheer for my fellow my fellow colonizer my second
colonizer my second dad or he'll get me or he's gonna he's
gonna get me guys for for my our second dad we have to root
for France they are what a dark day no Hello!
Hello!
Bonjour!
He's watching, guys.
He's watching.
Not the colonizer.
Never go against the dictator.
Hello, hello, everybody.
I am very tired.
Half-time.
Alright, for during half-time, sorry, my mustache has the
mind of it.
My mustache is not Mustaching very well right now But bear
with me Bear with me This is as good as it's gonna get What
are you not Dyer I fucked up my sleep schedule again Because
I was very stressed And you know what I do When I'm very
stressed Oh there's Bart That's our favorite guys
Everybody's I like how they, I like how they got the Polish,
uh, it's like Polish Mexican and who was the other person in
the VAR room.
I don't know if you guys saw, I thought it was really funny
that, um, I think what was it?
Like the finals and, um, for England versus Argentina, it's
like all American, all like, what's it called?
Conca Caff?
Is that what it's called?
Um, what do you mean?
We all love VAR.
Shadeo is watching.
Yeah, Conga Caffe.
Yeah, the refs for the finals and the England versus
Argentina are all like Conga Caffe refs too.
Poland, Netherlands, and Mexico on vibe.
Alright, here we go.
Also, shout out to Al.
Shout out to Al for giving birth to French doki.
Not only do Did they create British Doki?
They also created French Doki.
What powers they have.
Let's see.
With great power comes great responsibility.
Comes great shit posting.
I need to get my timer up again.
Sorcerer, think of this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, does someone need a stone cold sun or need to get to
sleep for once?
Think of this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's just whenever I get really, really stressed out, I end
up playing video games for a very, very long time.
It's not very healthy.
I don't know.
Guys, I think I need to fix my schedule.
Can you guys help me?
Sometimes I play.
And then you're like, stop playing video games later.
And I was like, guys, come on.
I need reasonable solutions.
here.
Man, this is not a joke, guys.
I need reasonable solutions that I can actually do.
No, you cannot.
Next, you think of the super chat?
Thank you.
Wait a second.
You're just reinventing Italia, but we'll do that.
No, that's, that's Miku Hatsune.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, and thank you for the super chat.
Oh, Oh my god, French Doki feels right.
First X, uh, X-Mission 33, now Doki.
France is winning, guys.
Thank you to the Super Chat.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they started?
Wait, you're supposed to wait for me.
What do you mean you started?
Oh, I'm so behind.
Give me a sec.
You're supposed to wait for your fellow Frenchman.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, that's nuts.
Oh my god, that's 19 hours.
Give me a sec.
they didn't wait for their fellow frenchmen all right i got
30 second i didn't i didn't listen to the cat i'm so tired i
didn't listen to also also the reason why um i cheer i'm
cheering for france is that for me i know somebody will be
like oh uh uh i don't know for me the reason why i want
france to win it's because i want england to win for the
next the next semi-finals so we can bring back the hundred
year war because i think france what the was that past the
dictator's angry i'm gonna send you to the gulags um but i
think france versus england is a lot funnier to watch Due to
the history, due to the long history they have to get.
Because no matter which country win or loses during France
versus England, there will be a riot.
Finally, the sequel to one of my favorite wars.
Don't you favorite?
Spain.
the armada is here no but like i know spain look england
went with to a lot of wars with a lot of different countries
but i feel like france versus england is a classic i feel
like we gotta bring back the classic wars you know what
other war can you remember that was a hundred years
historical even yeah i know spain used to rule the waters
but guys had did spain go into a hundred years of war with
england though i don't think so is there a is there a train
between i don't want to see that train closed down i like
the wow the train between france and england has closed down
I want yeah 113 years too I'm here for 130 oh what the fuck
I heard Spain invented Haramba also that too oh my god
there's the dictator you don't need a pass just right I
don't want peace I want but also another reason why I rune
against Spam.
They are the inventors of... They know what they did.
They know what they did to football.
What the fuck was...
Okay, Francis Passes are like actually dog shit right now.
They know what they did.
They ruined they metacrafted, ruined football forever.
The origin.
You know what you did to football.
What do you mean?
Reasons to not support Spain.
They beat my Germany back in 2008 and my Netherlands back in
2010.
Now they beat my Portugal and my Belgium.
Get them, Bop.
Thank you for the super chat, Ego.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, these classes are dog shit.
Bop, babe, quick.
Get the crowbar.
It's time to fire someone.
during the match.
Make the call right now.
Escort the coach out of the field.
Haram Valor being French.
What is, that is hard.
That.
I wonder like if the stadium is like pro French or, oh, of
it's not.
What am I saying?
A crime worse than being English.
No, actually, no.
Being English is worse.
That was so...
Actually, can't tell.
France and England have both colonized a lot of, a lot of
countries.
It is worse it's neck and neck see this is why I want the
finals to be France versus England imagine being English and
French Canada yippee yippee yippee we're the best of both
worlds we're both French and English equal Will it exchange?
The battle.
The battle of the...
That's true!
Wait, that's true!
Who colonizes harder?
Where am I looking at?
What is this game?
Fucking murder each other already!
Oh, wait, they can't.
They're playing with the inventor Haramba.
Alright.
oh shit did you guys know i don't yeah by the way uh because
uh world cup i learned the existence of what's the game
called galic ball galic galic ball which is like football
but you can use it but it's like what if foot we can play
football and rugby at the same time
oh shit bro what the fuck are these passes
how does that work I don't I don't know but apparently it's
very popular somewhere in the world it was a full house in
the stadium I actually used to play touch rugby before I
didn't play like normal rugby what the fuck are those passes
bro the dictator is not happy Alright, it's the first seven
minutes and I saw like five fumbled passes already.
Yeah, where is Mbappe?
Is it Mbappe or Mbappe?
I feel like people pronounce it out of way.
Bro, it's fucking stand the fuck up.
You fucking colonized countries and you can't take a hit in
the shin.
Like, get the bars!
He's diving!
Get the bars out of them!
Is it...
Oh, Mbappe?
Yeah.
Bro, get the fuck up.
Your ancestors are disappointed in you right now.
They were in wars.
She's so real, Frisas.
The dictator has taken another.
Oh, Mbappe.
Mbappe.
This is what happens when you stop colonizing.
It's okay, trying to figure out...
I'm just saying!
I bet you, if football...
If they were playing football back in that time, they won't
care about some kicks in the shins.
Guys, I'm so tired.
Don't say that.
What the fuck are they waiting for?
What is he...
What is that?
What it?
Oh, he forgot his spray.
Guys, we can't kick guys.
He needs to, he needs to draw on the field.
Right here.
Guys, it's tough.
And you must paint the floor real quick.
I don't know the power rankings from Spain.
You said France is currently a higher, but that is a fucking
close-ass foul.
Oh, shit, whatever.
He's just like, don't want that guy to have kids, I guess.
Oh shit!
Oh, that guy does not know how to jump.
That guy.
What the fuck?
Why did you jump?
Bro.
Easiest setup of your life that got soft.
Those Spaniards got soft, guys.
Ever since they stopped conquering the waters.
They can't even jump anymore.
He didn't find a jump button.
Oh, see, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, am I, like, super loud?
Wait, I'm so quiet.
What do you mean?
Does that can't turn your mic all the way down?
What do you want?
Why?
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, see, thank you, thank you.
Turn it up.
He wants us.
That ain't bad.
Because you're French.
Oh, shit.
Look at that.
Look at it.
If this was England right now, he'd be falling.
That's right.
Nobody's safe.
Pew, pew, pew.
It's okay.
It's because I'm French.
I can say that.
You know, it's just banter with the English, guys.
English.
English dokey would understand.
England.
English joke you would understand.
Nobody's sick.
Guys, it's just football.
It's just pure football.
Since when?
This is Italia at home.
Instead of hot, hot men.
You get hot to me.
right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you
don't sound i'm sound very french it's breaking my immersion
kill you get the best
also i'm very bad at accents what the fuck are those fucking
passes We just need a clone in BAPE.
He's just...
Thank you, listen, reach out.
Thank you.
Honestly, I think I know what we need to do.
We need a clone in BAPE.
Yeah, I think that sounds French, right?
One day.
One day in 20...
I don't know.
2082 or some shit.
We'll get a team full of imbapes.
If only French you know is spy from...
I would say he is the best French role model.
He actually makes people want to be French.
Oh my god, that guy did a fucking tumbleweird.
Oh my, get the fuck up, bro.
bro back in back in the good old days what was that bro a
rug bird grass bird what the fuck was oh okay wait naturally
no that hurts actually never mind no you're cool no that
hurt
never mind saw the metal studs and it never got never by all
is good oh back in my day imbabe passes to imbabe imbabe
shot shoots and imbabe scores imagine though oh my god
imagine if you're like all right so you remember like last
world uh last world cup game with um argentina versus
scotland and when we talk about how like oh wait they're so
free don't worry there's no third second person there to
yell at them it's oh my oh wait imbabe is gonna imbabe Papa,
you can 1B7 that.
It's okay.
We didn't have another.
What's his name?
Stootland and Holland drama.
Whatever the Stofy.
Stofy and Holland drama.
Oh my god.
The other goal is like, oh shit.
I should die.
Wait a minute.
I gotta do my job.
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Switch it out for three days.
And Doki already suggesting crimes against humanity.
Thank you.
Super chat.
imagine okay so like this is the plan you know if you were
like really really love football and you're a football
player and you want like you know you're like you you play
the long game you know you plan for the future so you marry
another like holland he married another football player but
what if you plan this out you know so it's like not just
like so you plan this out with your bro Because like, you
need like what 11 players on the field or or yeah, 11
players on the field.
So what you do is that you and your bros, you know, after a
World Cup, you do like a little pack and stuff and said
like, because like you can do this with like what separate
with like the project with like three to four players.
And you can make the oh shit what the fuck was that that
push?
what the fuck bro you shouldn't fucking dive there if it
worked for england it can work for france so okay you need
14 to 15 all right so you can okay divide that we can divide
that with five players right so all you need each player
just gotta have like two to three kids and so so you know it
could be like Project Norway, because like Holland already
started, like got started.
Any other country can also try it out.
So it could be like Project Holland.
Because like, I feel like Holland was genetically engineered
to literally play football.
And hear me out.
To create the ultimate World Cup team.
You know, whatever kids suck at, there's always round two.
And then round.
that's the that's the fun part about experimenting
we had it we could create not just the ultimate player but
the ultimate team
see like a lot of pro players they like a lot of like pro
world cup players or football players they marry like you
know beautiful models beautiful celebrities But you can
also, but like, if, if we get an entire country to agree to
be like football and football player, we could create the
ultimate World Cup team.
We could just split it between five.
Imagine, you could actually have a team of all Hollands.
But like, one is like, well, Holland is a tank build.
Like he can't run for too long.
So, like, imagine, okay, imagine if you have, like, Holland,
but, like, he can run for a long time.
Yeah, we can genetically engineer the perfect World Cup
team.
Yeah, he has low stamina.
We sort of distributed the stats wrong.
Tokyo is discovering eugenics.
Yeah, imagine Holland, but he can run long for much longer.
He's more than his alt.
So it's like it's a limit.
It takes three days for Toki to go full eugenics.
And this is why we need neutral countries.
They go to Super Chat.
They get thick.
Guys, I have a feeling the stadium is full of Spaniards.
I have a feeling.
That's like unethical.
What do you mean?
Holland and his girlfriend.
What the fuck is that, bro?
Please.
Bro, what did he expect?
Bro, what the fuck did he expect?
Bro.
He's like, I gotta do it.
He knows.
Bro, yeah, like, what?
Why is he acting surprised?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
It's not.
She was his childhood sweetheart that they meant via
football camp.
So it's not unethical.
We just got to recreate that multiple times.
We got to have the World Cup football camp.
See, if we got like a bunch of like football players
together for football camp, it's not us manufacturing.
We're not matchmaking.
They're all just happening, happens to play football.
to get there.
You know?
Oh, so that's like, bro, like, that guy, that guy knew
what's going to happen doing that.
He was just like, I'm doing it for Spain.
Like, he knew.
The moral of the plot to the Gattaca, there is a reason
eugenics is bad.
Yeah, it's like we all got them at the Olympic Village, but
we, like, get rid of the...
Oh, shit.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, yeah, I was in... Bro, that's so cheap.
Come on, bro.
I rather you just play Haran Ball.
Oh, yeah, I heard Yamala is 19.
Yeah.
The referee's going against the dictator.
This will not end well.
Oh!
Come on, bro.
Come on, friends, you know what to do now.
If it works for them, it'll work for you.
Goal, I guess.
I guess it's a goal.
I like how...
Oh, yeah, they're on the way jersey.
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
I felt like that penalty was pretty questionable call.
Like, like, he knew what he...
What was going to happen?
He fucking knew what was gonna happen too When he did that
When he did that charge The sacrifice He made for his
country Of Spain Is a better colonizer It was just an Honest
kick in the butt Yeah but him Going after for that block He
knew what was gonna happen That guy was just trying to get
He's like, no!
And the Spanish!
That fucking kid is just like, yeah, I hate that kid's gonna
grow up to hate the Spaniards.
The dictator and Papa is gonna be oh no, that kid's gonna
grow up racist.
No one can escape the Spanish Inquisition.
I don't understand.
We're not even in the water.
Oh yeah.
The witch's curse is actually delayed.
It has a cool down.
This is how the villains are made.
I'm sorry.
I'm a bit more unfiltered today.
Because I'm French right now.
And also.
Welcome to Patty.
I'm giving you the, I'm giving you the petty experience,
guys.
If you had a translation, if you had a translation device
and you're in Paris right now.
And I'm tired.
No, I ain't not telling.
Tiki kick is bullshit because it's, I don't know.
It's just pretty chill, you know.
Like, it's, it's just a very, cheap penalty a very cheap
foul because that guy you tell like he knew what was gonna
happen to him he's like oh no my butt oh no my glutes ref
ref he touched my butt without my consent can I please have
a penalty sir it was well played by the Spanish player
that's why he did it
time i have to go walk dad i have a lot of time too so i
didn't walk him i woke up and went straight to this but
because i did not sleep a lot today as well i walked dad
late at night so like i still have time oh yeah also also
right after the normal like you know you know how it takes a
little bit of uh incubation period like a little what's that
what's called where a little bit of a waiting period
post-England, like post-Norway versus England.
The amount of, the amount of Jude X Holland things I saw in
my timeline, it's literally people were like, I think the
heated rivalry, fandom has found cleated rivalry.
i was curious i was curious um of like just how how what's
the word what what it had awakened in a lot in a lot of
people so obviously my the
the the one the one indicator is to check how many fanfics
are in oh shit they're playing how many fanfics are in
archive of our own and i swear to god i went on that site i
looked it up um i looked it up and then like every time i
refresh five new fanfics were getting published per sec per
refresh and it was like every 10 seconds there were five new
fanfics being public it awakens something deep inside they
have found the football they have found the football fandom
i let me check now i know exactly it was like around 400
when i looked holland
men's football wow it jumped up by 200.
Oh my God, wait, is that Mbappe?
You can't beat him.
Join him.
There's 200 fanfics that, 200, actually 300 plus fanfics
have been made since two days ago.
Were those fanfics written by LeDokie.
Lego, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Emil, they give the super chat.
Hey, I hope, Doki, I hope you're doing well.
I was wondering if there was something you'd do about the
delay.
It's like 14 seconds Behind.
Oh, is it?
Is it 14 seconds behind?
This is my current.
Sorry.
Because, like, we're west coast.
We're further away from France.
We're further away from Quebecois.
From Quebec.
So, that's, like, the 14-second Quebec delay.
No.
If I lived, if I live in Quebec, It'd be more in real time.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine Fuji Orange's story as the World Cup.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Check what country is it from and was it colonized by the
Spanish?
Check his birth.
Check his country of origin and trace back his lineage.
See if there's any colonizers in them.
I'm gonna let him out.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how did he get subsed out?
He had...
Were they...
There were any spies?
They planted them everywhere.
It's like the Magolians.
Well, what country is it?
We're like...
There's a country where...
That's like...
Like 80% or 90% of people living there can trace their
origin back.
to the Mongolians because they conquered a lot.
Yeah, to like Attila the Hun or the Huns, yeah.
All of Asia.
Was it all of Asia or Genghis?
I don't know.
They both, both of them did a lot.
Is it like all of Asia that's like, it could trace their
origins back to Genghis Khan or Attila the Hun?
some shit because they love to conquer oh my god distract
him with your hair that's right with your hair he doesn't
know what to do it's all hair he's distracted like i was
just like whoa that's why shake your hair into his face
i feel like it's a good strat he got confused
Where's he trying?
A good pass.
I mean, that was a great pass.
Not gonna lie.
Pushed it.
That was a really good pass to the goalkeeper.
A good pass,
bro.
National League of Super Channel.
Thank you.
Open wide for some soccer.
My channel has briefly become a soccer channel for the
last...
The last three weeks.
I wonder if I stream something, whether I go back to a
regular program.
Like, I feel bad for the, I feel really bad for the
non-football fans.
They've been waiting for content for so long, but we've been
stuck in football at Purgatory.
Guys, guys, to the non, they won't watching anyway but
I was like to the non-football viewers they're not joking
they're not watching they've already unsubscribed but if
you're still somehow here guys we only have this once every
four years and then it's back to your channel back to your
regular schedule oh shit nice deal
I was just like But I'm still here, though.
Please give us something.
I will sub again after football ends.
Where is he aiming?
He's like, what's a free ball?
This is a plus one charity work.
He's going to put that in his taxes later.
I gave a ball to a fan.
What the fuck is this guy?
Oh, a Super Bowl guy.
Oh, fake football.
The sport that only Americans watch.
Oh, yeah, apparently I learned that, like, to bypass the
whole, like, What the fuck?
Oh, oh, shit.
Like, what was he thinking?
The dictator.
The dictator saw this.
We'll remember this.
Oh, it was offside.
Bro, okay, thank God that was offside and that did not make
it.
What?
What's that?
Okay, it's a foul.
He's like, you ain't got your ball.
Rans is playing super sloppy right now.
Guys, if only we had a team of 11 and Boppys, guys.
Perfect comp.
All DPS.
It's like...
This is all...
Oh, my God.
Bro.
What do you mean he literally tripped on the grass he's like
breath the grass is French Guys I have the perfect cop it's
like 11 DPS 11 dictators guys imagine if we had a team full
of 11 strikers which is an equivalent of 11 DPS goalkeeper.
The goalkeeper is going to just play outside the box.
Just think about it.
If he keeps striking, they will never need defense.
That guy was like my foot or some shit.
Why the fuck did he stop there?
I'm Bappe.
All right.
This is it.
Oh, that was very good.
What's the word?
That's
was a very uh what's that word not confident but like
ambitious yeah that's a very ambitious shot oh it was even
bopping who the fuck cares sorry i'm sorry
uh thank you to super chat thank you thank you i'm looking
forward to when doki switches to cheering for spain sir a
street kid what are you talking about i've never swapped
i've always There's been a firm supporter of France.
Oh, shit.
Okay, they were looking for another penalty.
Chia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There are two big football clubs.
Cup as well as the Women's World Cup next year.
You want to continue this football stream as a tradition,
Chia.
Thank you.
The super chat.
I don't know.
I think, like, there's something about World Cup.
That's just, I like World Cups more than, like, national,
like, more about, like, More than like football club teams
because like you get to be like extra.
What the fuck bad pass bad.
That was close
I like like like sports sport tournaments when it's like
country versus country versus like I guess like clubs versus
clubs.
It just feels much more.
What's so it feels much more Much more hype okay this is
like very bad like i i will have to spit say spain isn't
even playing haramba they're playing like half murder ball
right now and the french cannot keep it up guys they haven't
caught they've been getting super oh oh good head oh good
head wait bad head bad that's the wrong team you're supposed
to you're supposed to give good head to your team
They got too lazy.
They haven't colonized it so long.
Yeah.
Damn.
That's Yemel, right?
The other prodigy.
There's a lot of newcomers.
There's a lot of like...
Well, I mean, to be fair, like, you know, the current stars
of football are aging out right now.
So there's a lot of newcomers coming in to take over.
because we have like what we have miho what's his name I
forgot about miho who's younger who's like 17 holy shit 1v3
oh wait who filed who is like the villain oh yeah I heard
he's like super arrogant but that kid that kid's 19 oh shit
hey there I will say like being like that famous at 19 Like
any like anyone would turn evil like I feel like I feel like
that's the what
like all the women or men we don't know we don't know what
happened yeah
I feel like whenever you're exposed to so much like
attention and like publicity that young like and like I'd be
surprised if you're not evil like
There's a, he had the dictator started young.
Oh, is that an offside?
Did he offside?
Alright, what happened?
The 6-7 kid turned evil?
Bro, that kid's just depressed.
Do you see like the, like, where Disney invites?
You know, like, when the joke is, like, even he's like,
it's, no longer funny anymore when the corporations uh try
to do be do the may mays to be hit with the kids and like
the six seven kid well he's not even a kid anymore he's like
a teenager now uh and they invited him to disney to teach
mickey and his the gang six seven and it's it's so cringe
the video is so awkward like you could tell he's not into
like the hearts he's not into the His heart's not in it
anymore.
His heart's not into the 6-7 anymore.
Spain is so...
Holy shit, bro.
Okay, that's like every time the goalies do that, it's so
scary.
Holy fuck, that's a good pass.
You're so much faster!
Oh, shit!
Quake is out of his house!
They forgot his keys!
He forgot his keys!
like quick that was so risky yeah like cool he's like oh
shit he's like wait a minute why is he here that is so risky
if he didn't hit that shot if if the goalie missed that
would that was so fucking scary
oh come on guys that oh wait oh wait wait friendly fire
apparently if a goalie hits their hits their teammate they
have to call what happened to the guy we don't even know
what happened to the guy on the floor but if a if a the
goalie hits like his teammate they have to call a timeout.
So it's like for the greater good you know?
He's got to take one of his own out.
Yeah but if he if the if his teammate went down because of
his punch in the head they technically get a timeout.
He's like please please please you know how I you know how I
fuck with you guys and I got penalty kicked before please
please.
how you did that to the other fresh player.
Like, please.
Come on.
You know, it was just a joke.
He's just like, oh, fuck.
Please.
It was just a joke.
Why are you praying?
Oh, no.
You don't like it when it happens to you, Spade?
Oh, yeah.
Can't take it.
Can't dish what you take.
Oh shit It was just a prank bro please Alright who's Wait Oh
what was that?
He's like Where the ball go Alright sub that guy That guy is
confused 90% of the time He's just like Where the ball go
Play stupid games Win stupid prizes What's the phrase?
You can't take Was it can't dish out what Can't remember
that phrase right now He got too much hair
Where am I He's just like Fucking again Sacra blah
You can dish it but can't take it
Guys Guys believe And Boppe's alt is charged guys in the
patch notes um his it says his alt charge is 20 faster now
so don't worry he's gonna alt soon guys all right six
minutes what is that ball hand ball he's touching the ball
Handball!
Look at that!
That's a foul right there!
He touched it!
Rev!
No, these passes are fucking dog shit, bro.
He's charging his up.
He credos it like a baby.
He's like, my baby.
See if the thing detects signals.
Oh, good pass.
That pass was so good, too.
See, if Bumpe was here, he'd take the shot.
That's actually a good pass, too.
Head!
Bro, the amount of people getting knocked down in Spain's
team, Yeah, it's France, France that fucking swapped out a
player because some because of the injured player
Oh, it's a national holiday right now over there It's never
in Bappe's fault guys.
It's his team
Yeah, it's because the French are just the French team is
not really good at acting
They didn't take enough acting classes
you're right the spanish has the soap opera buff you're so
right that's not fair there's they have soap operas what
do the french have
bread what is bread gonna do for oh shit foul foul
Come on!
Give him a red card!
You're right.
It's not black and white, so it's a debuff.
If this game wasn't black and white, the acting would be
better.
Oh, shit.
Wait, is the flag upside down?
I literally...
Oh, my God, it is.
I got the reverse flag.
This is...
Guys, this is why we were losing.
Guys, I cannot remember flags, man.
They're all...
There's so many different colors.
Guys, guys, it's fine.
It's like, you know, we're...
That's why...
That's why Francis is losing.
Please understand.
I'm on the other side of the world.
So then I flipped it.
Reverse the spade.
Whoa, that's...
That's true.
Maybe if I reverse the Spain flag Give you a sec So true, so
true It's like What was it?
I remember there's like something in bad luck Oh, it's like
the horseshoe if you reverse it It's bad luck There's so I
remember like apparently the Norway If you take the Norway
flag you can make like Eight different countries out of the
Norway flag
All right, halftime.
I mean, it's pretty close, though.
Doki was such a fan of guillotine.
She was rooting for 1790s for us.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There you go.
I flipped it around.
It's like the cross, you know?
When the cross is flipped, you're inviting the devil inside.
Like, yeah.
It's still anyone's game.
Oh, shit.
I gotta walk dad.
Okay.
I'm gonna come back and walk my dog real quick.
Let me put this thing.
Walking my dog during half time.
Uh.
There you go.
Let me grab this real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
It's dog walking time.
I'll be right back.
Entertain yourselves.
Dominate you, Dragoon, to be the leader.
Yes, I'm talking about you.
You're the leader for now.
Get it back just in time.
Oh, shit.
Have you guys enjoyed?
Did you guys enjoy hanging out together?
All right, let's see.
I need to redo this.
I'll sabotage.
You know what?
I don't want to say it's coincidence or not, but...
uh welcome back it's been a thousand years all right did you
guys started kissing he's like donkeys back stop kissing
stop making out
what the fuck
i was gonna say i don't want to say it's fate or anything
but uh but in the elevator There was a French woman.
At my co-worker's French National Living Brought.
So half the office got...
What a cool...
Oh, man.
Must have been a virus that only hit the French.
Thank you, Mr. Richard.
Thank you.
So there was a French woman in the elevator.
And I...
You know...
And she was a really pretty French woman.
So you know dad was going crazy.
Anyway, so I thought that was the last French, uh, the last
French meeting I had, I've had, I'll have today.
But then, um, uh, but then, uh, when I went to the dog park,
there was a French bulldog.
And not only was it a French bulldog, it was a female French
bulldog.
And the dad went even crazy.
Because normally, he wouldn't care about the gender of the
dog.
But then, the French female bulldogs on there was also a
French woman.
A very beautiful French woman.
So, that was like, oh my God.
So many choices.
And only one dad.
So, that's why it took me a while to, like, come back up.
Because he was like, he's like, oh.
Ula la la let me smell this female french boy who didn't
give a fuck about him by the way because that that french
bulldog was like two times bigger than him and then dad was
like Ula la can I smell you can I like that the the female
bulldog was literally just sitting down and then dad was
just like stuffing his nose under and I'm like I'm so sorry
I'm and then the the owner was like it's okay he must not
see a lot of women and i'm just thinking he sees a lot of
women but then like the french bulldog did not give a fuck
about him she was just sitting down and then he was like
just jamming his nose under there and he's like and
like madame ma'am and yeah and and it's like the other Dog
just did not care.
That is freaky.
And then afterwards, he went up to the other lady and he's
like, ooh, like, can you touch me?
Can you also, you know, it's like, he's like, ooh.
So I have four legs.
One leg for each woman.
That slide, dog.
And then he was like, yes, touch me.
the both worlds
oh shit ref cab powered by Lenovo he's like what I didn't do
nothing so that's why it took me a while because like half
time is like what 15 minutes it took me a while to come back
dad was very preoccupied because the thing is I couldn't go
until he pooped but he refused to poop until he is french
french women time anyway i won't i don't know if it's i
don't know if it's fate or not but three french encounters
oh breath didn't call that's right you know get the fuck
back you're 19 you grow another leg if you want to like oh
these passes are terrible what happened
oh yeah i forgot to tell you guys this story so i ordered
like dog food because he He has a particular specific diet
that he uses.
I mean, he doesn't have kidney issues.
What was that?
Is he planking?
Like, he's like, my leg and my shoulder and my neck.
Oh, good acting.
Good acting.
Cast that man in neck soap, opera.
But like, so I order his dog food off of Amazon because it's
like a wet diet.
It's like a vet, like a veterinarian wet food diet.
Just because, like, I just didn't want to risk it anymore.
Ever since he had, like, when he got diagnosed with kidney
issues, which he somehow fucking recovered from.
Even though when he first got diagnosed, they were saying
how, like, this is uncurable or whatever.
And then later on, when he got tested again, they were like,
oh, it's gone now.
And I'm like, oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Go, go, go, kick, go kick, go kick.
It touched him, guys.
It touched your mouth.
yeah and uh so i would i ordered i ordered like two boxes
because i i you know just so like i don't have to like keep
just it's convenient just have this pile stockpiling it
versus like me forgetting to and then being like oh shit i
have one can left anyway so i thought it was really fun this
is the first time this ever happened um i've never had this
happen before like i've never so basically
I think it was when I ordered food or something But like I
opened the door And I saw the box was open And I think like
one of my delivery guys One of the Uber Eats guys Wanted to
steal the package But he wanted to see what's inside the
I've never had this happen before by the way Wanted to see
what's inside the package Saw it was all dog food and just
left it Because the package was open It was like ripped yeah
It was just like ripped open And it was just like the lid
was open And you see the dog food
I thought Like I thought it was funny He's like I'm gonna
steal this package like oops all dog food It's never
happened before because you can't The thing is you can't
access my floor Unless you live on my floor Like that's how
tight the security is Other than food deliveries Because you
can give them access to the uh to your floor for like
one-time access to your floor so even like i have a package
stolen or whatever like like it i would know who it was
because only you know only packaged only like uh food
delivery guys are the only people accessing my floor
i know it was funny he's just like oh it's just it's dog
food i'm not stealing that it's expensive dog food it's like
a hundred dollars a box not can it's like just like a box
has like 12 cans it's like a hundred canadian dollars that
guy did not know how oh my god that is so risky what they
can't even pass through their own goalie the dictator will
remember this i don't know i didn't care too much i should
have though i should have said i should have wrote something
by that time i was just tired i didn't the dog food is so
the dog food package is still outside by the way it's been
out there for at least four days
it's like a special yeah it's a hundred dog hundred kidney
dogs because it's a special uh it's a special uh wet food
diet okay uh for kidneys it's for specifically uh for
sensitive kidneys and i don't want dad to pee out his
protein again i don't know he fixed himself i don't know how
I was gonna say what pass was that.
Oh my god.
I was like, does he know?
Bro, these passes, man.
Go, yeah, go back to summer camp.
This is not like semi.
Good pass.
This is like, bro, this is the semi-finals, man.
Like, what the fuck?
This is so sloppy.
This is literally semi-finals.
Like, oh my god, I was gonna say, what the fuck was that?
It is so sad to watch.
Like, group stage France was better.
What?
Did he trip on his balls?
Like, where did he trip?
He tripped on, the whole point is dribbling a ball, and then
you trip on it?
Oh, he got too cocky.
He got way too cocky.
that oh who's
foul is it oh hey why are we zooming in on the shirtless mad
whoa that guy plays soccer oh hey imbappe random lady hello
do you think she knows do you think you think she knows
I'm fucking ordering food this match sucks It sucks for my
country
Only if you're Spanish like yeah This sucks for the French
Sacra blue
Guys guys I believe.
I believe.
I believe, guys.
Just need two more girls.
What should I eat?
A wee wee.
A wee woo.
Wait, okay.
I thought you missed that pass.
As my favorite scientist would say.
Oh shit Oh shit Omlet do Fremage Which by the way is wrong
By the way It's inaccurate French Oh
shit No Bro
Guys, guys, guys, guys is not because I said omelet du
framage.
Yeah, guys, guys, I cursed them.
It's like a spell.
Omelet du framage!
Goodbye, dictator.
The dictator shall remember this.
I cast it a spell.
Omelet du framage.
The curse is, it's at a cool down period.
The curse had a cool down period.
But guys, it would have been so funny if it was Trads vs.
England.
My 100 year war dreams.
My 100 year war sequel.
I've been waiting for the sequel.
It's so long.
Almost made a hundred years.
Yeah, he only had one life.
Mbappe had only one life.
It's like, Essie had like, how many, has like X amount of
charges.
So she had to recharge her cool.
It's like, because it was a new round.
So she had to, every round she has to recharge, you know?
move over the um um that's not true i predicted every
country i want to win win carl thank you super chat thank
you thank you yeah she had to reload that first that first
game where france was like reload the global cooldown the
final is ruined i wanted my colonizer versus oh to be is
also it but still my hundred year war sequel i have oh my
god give me i'll be right back at
uh uh do not worry miss me i'm just gonna go get milk real
quick but i'll be back
okay at least that's offside At least, at least we got
offside.
At least.
You know, it's the little things, guys.
At least it's not 3-0.
At least.
Sorry.
Or blah, this is me.
I'll be back.
I'm getting some milk, guys.
Just getting some milk, everybody.
Ah!
Andle!
Toro!
Hello everybody Hi Hola Hola everyone I am Spade Doki Hola
Adela Adela Toro Toro
Hello Hola Hola Hola Everyone
Hola amigos Hola Hola Get your pommaham ready for siesta
time!
We're gonna be si- What is this?
Ayah!
Hola, amigos!
That's right, I got my red cape to bait the filthy French
into getting a red card.
Oh, are you mad?
Are you mad, you baguettes?
Ole!
And Papay will remember this.
Oh yeah, let me change the...
Oh, sorry, what did French dokey?
All French dokey didn't change the score.
Typical French dokey, making the Spaniards do all the work.
Look at that.
Guys, guys, like I said, every stream I predicted the
correct team.
went from baguette to paella in a heartbeat mike thank you
what do you mean i've always been spanish dokey hola amigos
oh give me a sec let me um
ah and papa and papa washed more like snooze papa Am I
right, my fellow Spaniards?
Let's get some palm of hand after this.
Amigos?
Neil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I saw it.
Run from Le Doki to El Doki.
Like, you're thinking with super chat.
Thank you.
Ole!
Yeah.
Dictatorships don't stay forever.
We're having a revolution.
The Spanish Inquisition has arrived.
I'm so good at picking teams, guys.
Ole!
No
one ever expects it.
the battle of the colonizers
100% win rate shout out to Alette Alette did not believe in
the French Alette was like do you want me to make draw
something for Spain and I didn't say anything because I,
because French Doki believed and then Alette sent this in
they didn't believe
Alec didn't believe And then Spanish dokey was Was born Wow
Alec nose ball Who's your favorite Who's your favorite dokey
so far Who's your favorite dokey He's chef.
Bola's taking the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, talk.
It's time to go to a time in Hombapé.
The future is now.
I was spain the whole time.
I was always Spanish.
We can all agree.
I was always the colonizing.
Where the fuck was he shooting that?
What is that, Boppy?
Okay, I feel like half the French team does not know what
was going on.
They don't know the game plan.
Good pass.
Snooze Boppy.
See, Napoleon lost at one point.
This is their loss, too.
What, offside?
Yemel's gonna get all the bitches after.
God where's the offside is a tie just cut his arm up just
cut his arm off at that point every time you offside just
cut it off bring back the guillotine
imagine imagine john laser comes down from the sky of your
offside now then no one will be offside guys just think
about it no one can no one one-off side of a giant laser
comes from the sky and chops it off.
Think about it, guys.
What?
Good!
Yeah!
Good acting!
What was that?
Heart crash?
Was it?
Yeah, Matador.
Holy shit!
Bros.
play fucking rugby.
Oh, my...
Yeah, no, that has to be a yellow Not a yellow guy, bro.
That was a fucking car crash.
Holy shit.
Bro, we heard, we can hear the screaming from here.
He got, pop, pop.
He actually got hit and run.
That!
It's the red.
The French saw the red.
Toro, Toro, Adelaide.
That's right.
He saw the red again.
Yeah, he got it.
Got it.
And then he got angry.
Bro, that guy actually got rugby.
All right, let me see what food to get today.
Let's see.
I want to eat some Hong Kong food today.
Oh, hold on, I'm going for maybe.
Maybe I have some Hanani's chicken rice.
That, I think, I think they're getting, we're about to get a
riot.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're in a French jokie go.
He went to, she went to get milk real quick.
Just went to get, uh, went to get milk, guys.
Guys, guys, we gotta go bull running after to celebrate.
Get that Russian.
Olay And they get Parma ham after That is my extent of
knowledge Sports with bulls And Parma ham And Olay Oh and
salsa Yeah salsa I think that's all I need I think I can't
believe French jerky surrendered.
Actually, yes, I...
Oh, and Paella.
Paella!
Ole!
But Parma, I like Parma Ham more.
Spain is using their old Techni Domain expansion.
Cotera, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ah, yes.
In typical French fashion, they raised a white flag.
And also, my knowledge was...
Spain also from Hitalia.
The Spain Hitalia song.
Maracaque, Chiquu.
I actually love...
Okay, despite the...
All...
All the controversies with Hitalia, their opening is fire.
It is very catchy.
Maracaque, Chiquu.
Marikai Chikyu Oh yeah and also Pussin boots
Alright I didn't get to order my food You know what to
celebrate I should order some paella Honestly as a longtime
supporter Of Spain Who always believed I should order some
paella That's what Mbapa Gonna do He's old with three
bitches.
Let's go.
To celebrate as a longtime Spain supporter.
Yeah.
And Bappe more like wash Bappe.
Oh!
Got him!
Ole!
It is really funny.
moment also get a wife like victoria beckham who does not
give a fuck about soccer like you guys see that photo when
england scored a goal beckham was like yeah and then
victoria beckham's just like it's been like how many years
since she has married she's been married to david beckham
and she still does not give a fuck about soccer since day
one since fucking day one we love supportive wives more than
two decades apparently like that's why beckham did not uh
there was a documentary where you know i don't remember the
90 98 world cup where he got a red uh where he got a red or
some shit like my boy and pa and what's his name the swiss
guy he did something like that but in like was it the finals
right and yes she is indeed is posh by and everyone in
england hated beckham but then like he was like but whenever
he comes home victoria did not know what the fuck was going
on so she did not care he was like that was the only thing
that was keeping me saying during Is that my wife just did
not fucking care.
Because she did not care about football.
He's just like, whatever.
At least he can come home.
Knowing that his wife does not know what's going on.
That's crazy.
Bro, you're supposed to get injured when you're in the
fucking box.
Oh shit, it's Yamele versus Mbappe.
The future is now, old man.
It helped me work life balance.
My man and his silly hobbies.
Yamele actually being like, future is now.
Olen.
A little to the left.
Yeah.
Oh, nice fake.
Oh, nice head.
I don't even know how I got into the conversation about
Victoria Beckham.
Oh, yeah, and I also found out, apparently in Norway, in
Norway, people don't get married or some shit.
Is that true?
It's not common for people to have wives or husbands.
Because they're, like, Holland's not married to his...
girlfriend yeah apparently
you just hang up yeah I don't know if it's true or not but
people are saying that it's like people just live with each
other not like they don't get married they just live with
each other I don't know if that's true or not I don't know
if that's just Twitter fucking inventing more Holland lies
Oh yes, because he's married to Bellingham Yep, the
girlfriend is just like Just the beard He married Bellingham
in Las Vegas
He's married to Jude The girlfriend is like It's like, um,
What is it?
You know how like, uh, like, I can't, I don't want to say
concubine, but I don't know what else, like, you know how
there's like the main wife and then there's like the, and
then there's the side wives.
Like, there's another word for that, not, yeah.
The side, the side.
I mean the mistress yes the husband and the mistress it's
like work girlfriend and work work boyfriend work husband
it's like work husband and then girlfriend they needed to
get together to create the perfect football player guys you
don't understand it was it was like government man dated but
they had they got to get they got his son to create the
perfect genetically the second generation the second
generation of soccer players do
you guys hear that ever since holland got really popular
through ever since the world cup like what was it 500 babies
in peru are named after holland i don't know why peru in
general uh not even not even like norway but just in Peru
yeah they it's either they named them after they are like
named them after like or was it what's his first name I just
know him as a Holland that's crazy yeah I was just like damn
just in Peru I showed up on Twitter I get all my news on
Twitter Erlen.
Yeah, they either named the kid Erlen or Erlen Holland.
Or Holland.
Their first name would just be Holland.
Damn.
It's alright.
France is used to failing.
I can't tell if the stadium is like...
What?
Oh
my god, they found a new goalkeeper.
They... Bro!
How do you fuck that up?
The guy didn't... Wasn't even home.
No, bro, the guy wasn't, he didn't, another guy broke in
just to do his job.
Someone else had to do his job, bro.
This is actually, this is the, is this the worst Francis
ever played?
Is this, the goalkeeper was like, oh shit, I forgot, that's
my job.
He was actually, he thought it was hydration break.
Bro, this goalkeeper is fucking.
crazy.
He's so this is actually the saddest bro face that's the
dictate oh shit he's just like if I can't win I'll make sure
he can't play next in the finals holy shit there's just like
i'll make sure you don't exist in the finals oh my god oh oh
bro he did look at him spin though look at that look look at
that 360.
is this nose okay what is this nose is it like did he get
like rhinoplast like ride injected rhino serum into his nose
that dictated him Bob and kicked the gold keeper.
You know he's mad.
Spain has better gold keepers.
They're just resting right now for the real game.
Yeah, no.
The reason why her curse didn't go up is that she was
reloading.
Nothing happened to him.
I don't know.
Ball to the fucking nose hurt.
it
reminded me you know like how oh this is like random this is
like there's not this little fun fact okay it's not fun fact
this this little oh it's it's unrelated to what we were
talking about but there was a kid that inject from brazil
that injected like smashed butterfly uh parts and like just
like smash butterfly parts inside his body and then he died
from some shock what was it from septic is a septic shock
unfun fact and then apparently he did it for a tick-tock
video the eyes here about that that shows crazy imagine
injecting like crushed up butterfly into your body like what
do you think was gonna happen what are like literally just
smashing like smashing up some butterflies and just
injecting it inside yourself like what do you think that's
gonna do bro like you want you turn to butterfly man you can
start growing wings yeah i can't believe it's not
butterflies yeah some teenager in brazil he's gonna become
but for someone for a fucking tiktok video and he of course
the kid went in the goddamn shock body was meant to take in
crushed up butterflies in your blood system I don't know I
don't know we
don't know we don't know what you know you're right we
didn't know what was actually gonna happen if you crushed up
some butterflies inject on in yourself you know someone had
to test a theory out for a science What the fuck is the
goalkeep?
He's just like, I have nothing to lose.
I- What was he doing there?
Bro, Atu was like, bro, let me play.
I want to play.
I want some playtime on the field.
What the fuck was he doing?
That guy's giving up.
That guy's actually gave up.
Oh, I'm going to get bubble waffles.
I'm gonna get richer.
Did he kick another goalkeeper?
I told you!
Dictator and Bappe always remembers!
Bro, okay.
No, I don't.
That guy did not care.
Look at him.
Look at Dictator and Bappe.
He's just like, whoa.
Oh, whoops.
Did I do that?
Oh, oopsie.
Ole!
You got yellow card!
He did not care.
Oh, he's crashing out.
I keep crashing out right now.
He's just like, I will make sure you don't play in the
finals.
All right.
Bro's trying to make sure he does not make it in the finals.
We both won't be in the finals.
I will make sure you individually.
Whoa!
That jump!
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's a good defense.
The Embape special.
Bro, he didn't even care he got yellow.
He wasn't even gonna argue.
He knew what he did.
The fact that, like, Embape did not argue about the yellow
card.
He knew exactly what he did.
He's just like, yep.
And I do it again.
Oh, oh, oh
We cow and nope Oh shit, Yemel added again Use that 19, you
know, Yemel Miho needed to like be swapped off after half
time Because Miho gets tired Yemel doesn't get tired He's
got three girlfriends to go The more girlfriends you have
The more energy, the more power it up he has is.
He's got to get a fourth one in America.
Ole!
He's got that.
Oh!
And Bop it.
Yeah, that's why he has three girlfriends.
It's to train for this moment.
He's, yeah, he's trained.
See, this is why he has three.
They help him train for free.
FIFA.
bye-bye.
Ole!
Nice pass to the fans.
Good pass.
It's already over.
It might as well give the fans a ball.
Oh, shit.
No foul, though.
No foul.
What?
It's okay.
He's not.
Oh, shit.
He got jealous of those three girlfriends.
Maybe You should, guys, if my channel's gone, he's got
another one.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I'm not speaking French.
You won't know.
The dictator strikes again.
I will go down for the memes.
It's the hair, guys.
It's Kuchrella's hair.
It's the hair buff.
They're so distracted by the hair.
He's just swinging it around, guys.
He's swinging it around.
They don't know what to do.
Mbappe is not playing well this game.
Two of his entire team's playing like ass.
Like 90% of these passes were dog shit.
Spain is just playing really, really well too.
This is so sloppy from France.
Yeah, cuckoo, cuckoo, cuckoo- cuckoo-rella.
Oh, that's a fun name to say, cuckoo-rella.
It's like, it's like, the kuchiracha, the kukiracha,
pana-na-na-na-na.
The kukiracha, the kukiracha, pana-na-na-na-na-na.
The kukirala, the kukir-a-la, pana-na-na-na-na-na.
The kukirala, the kukirala-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
I don't keep police.
It's just a fun name.
That's a fun name.
I know that's Mexican.
But that's what it reminded me of.
Can't wait to get some paella after.
For my favorite country that I supported today.
And the only country I supported today.
Oh shit, they don't, it's no longer football.
What are they doing?
They're like, just, they're just keeping at home.
Wait, let me see.
Oh wait, I wanted bubble wubbles, but I feel like in honor
of my favorite country today, I should get a paella.
Da, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you, thank Thank you, Spain Mugs,
once again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you, holy shit, did you, is that on the field?
Did you hear that?
Someone's like, fuck out!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I want to know who said that.
That was in English.
Someone, someone, that, that, They swore, none of these
people are English, but they swore, and they, that was a,
that was, oh, that came from the heart.
Ole!
Ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole,
ole, yeah, that, that universal language.
Fuck out!
Oh my god, it's gonna be three, yeah?
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
Ole, ole, ole, ole.
Ole.
They all did.
As long as they don't cover the mouth, it's fine.
As long as it's not racist, and they don't cover their
mouths, it's fine.
Don't worry.
I'm supporting England tomorrow as a fellow colonized
Commonwealth.
Good pass!
Good pass.
Man, it's great that the French love passing when it
matters.
Don't worry.
Oh, no.
She's gonna grow up races too.
Get up, bro.
You're blocking the court.
You're blocking the field.
Get the fuck up.
We gotta support the king.
For God and country.
For the king.
I'm sorry.
For king and country.
I love.
His name is so fun.
bro just fucking stall your mail calm down your mail bro
what the i just give them one whatever who cares oh
yeah i'm not watching losers i'm sorry but no one really
cares about third place i'm sorry i'm sorry
wait unless okay i'll watch third place If it's France
versus England, I will watch third place.
If it's France versus England, I'll do it.
That's my 100-year war.
Hate the bronze confirm.
Bro, I'm bop...
Watch, boppy!
Snooze, boppy!
Choked, boppy!
Are we going to stream...
Yeah, I'm going to stream the...
Well, the collab is on Thursday.
Knox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Collab's on Thursday.
It's not...
Today's Tuesday.
That's fine.
Miss Bappe.
That's what the M stands for.
The M in M-Pappe stands for Miss Bappe.
Yeah!
Ole!
She does not care.
Yeah, the Spadders Inquisition wins again.
The schedule will be after this stream.
I was really tired.
I had a bad day yesterday.
I had a really bad day yesterday.
So I was just like, I was just being lazy and playing
rivals.
Because that's the only way for me to recover from a bad
day.
Yeah, the team I was.
supported the entire time wins yet again guys a hundred
percent prediction rate every time every stream yeah ole no
france played absolutely terribly i think I think France
played really badly.
They were...
I think this is like the sloppiest I've ever seen them play.
Andale, Toro.
Andale.
This is a sacra blue moment for dictating Poppe.
There you go.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Oh, yeah.
The timer.
Oh, stop.
Yeah, no.
They did have complete control of the ball.
I felt like it was mostly...
on it was always we won it was a sacra blowout true true
agree yeah we did it
yeah there was like like all the shots weren't even close
from the french side you know best part no haram ball that
was the best part they actually played like murder ball for
a for a sec too We did it!
We won!
Andre!
We
ball!
Yeah, actual football was played.
Yeah, on Spain's side.
Every time France got the ball, I was like...
Or...
Whenever France has the ball.
I don't know, your mouth's doing it.
doing later.
Getting that fourth girlfriend.
Let's go.
100% prediction rate.
Amalia.
Roja.
What does that mean?
Oh, one team has been decided in the finals.
That's crazy.
The, um, seven, was it 19 already at the finals?
That's actually crazy no wonder no wonder he's a little shit
no wonder he won
euros at euros at 17 18
bro that guy that little kid can tank shots bro that that is
just like i'm young i can regrow my
damn everything was against france they've never lost
against france at that point you should like maybe figure
something out that's three out of three he won euros at 16
bro and we're talking about holland i'm sorry that's i think
it's because he's like a little shit i think that's why
because you know holland's a great guy he's funny guy he's a
funny guy and he's like he's like funny and he seems he's
like a really wholesome guy and that's why like everyone
likes holland like so if you have like like your mouth known
to be a little so that's why like people don't like give him
the same amount of like praise and stuff compared to holland
he's a good player but he has like bad attitude he's like a
toxic gamer
Now he's, I told you, the future is now.
The new dictator, a new dictator has been born.
Yeah, I know.
I think, like, he's still a teenager, too.
Like I said, when you get famous super young, you turn a
little evil.
Sometimes you turn really evil.
Yeah.
Uh, no clarity.
They give a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the watch a lot, Adokie.
Always better with you and the dragons.
They give a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think like, um, they're, France is lucky that
today's a holiday.
Wait, that should know.
That means more time to riot.
We're all speak footy.
Whoa.
We do?
We did it, guys.
We did it again.
believe it a hundred percent prediction rate every team i've
predicted and cheer for has won the world cup i have a very
i have a clean record
who is we we we you guys are just jealous all right all
right you guys are just jealous guys i was a spy all
I was like a sleeper agent.
I said, I'm the dufermage!
And then I awakened.
Yeah, losing on your national holiday is crazy.
I request you to wear RGT colors and be in the next match,
so they curse, please, and thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I got to root my fellow Commonwealth.
That's the cream butter cake.
The king's going to get me, guys.
You know, the French.
No, no, no.
I heard the match.
I heard the code.
You know, the activation code.
I'm going to do fromage.
I heard the code.
Is Yemel 6-0 against Embape?
I think Biggie.
yeah I think like when you're like that young um you like
you get famous that young you tend to have a huge ego and
everything I think it's just I think it's just how life is
omelet oh from my no I'm talking about the my favorite my
favorite quote from my favorite scientists.
Omlet du vermage.
That's when you know I wasn't actually French.
Yeah, it's like, it was me!
Spanish jockey the entire time!
That's why it was my activation.
It was my sleeper agent activation, quote, to reveal that I
was not French!
I was actually Spanish!
It was an inside job!
Quilt, Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Just joined stream.
You're cheering for Spain.
Yep, I was cheering for Spain.
The entire time the mustache comes off.
No one ever expects the Doki Inquisition.
Have you no shame?
Woman, thanks for the stream.
Sive.
Boy, be traitor.
Boy, it's been Spanish.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sive.
Tomorrow, we will watch the England versus Argentina again.
And I'll be cheering for England.
And I'll cheer for England the entire time.
Of course, of course.
Because I have 100% prediction rate.
Yeah.
Anyway, guys, thank you for coming to...
Oh, my God.
They're partying.
Holy shit.
The Spaniards are partying.
Oh, yeah.
They're partying so hard.
when was the last time they were at the world cup
all right guys thank you everybody for watching today's game
with me i'm gonna head out i'm tired i also need to make a
schedule and i have a lot of stuff in my schedule right now
there's a lot of stuff right now to do so i'm gonna call it
here i usually would hang out longer but today um i just
have a lot on my plate today to catch up on uh jesus thank
you for super chat thank you oh my god is this jesus british
the hundred-year war was for anyway jesus knows he knows who
was on the winning side come on england score some fucking
goals thank you jesus for the super chat thank you thank you
anyway guys i'm gonna go head off now thank you all for
coming to watch me again for the for the watch a lot of the
world cup always always love doing these watch a lot so you
guys been really fun i feel like ever since holland got
eliminated though people america's just stopped gearing
like america's just like holland's got who cares i just
noticed i see like people are still talking about holland
yeah uh but yeah anyway guys um like even when he got
eliminated people are still talking about holland like like
what is holland doing right now like you know he's back in
norway and they're like what is holland doing in like norway
right now even though the world cup still going on like that
guys do you see holland with the rat with the raccoon like
yeah i did and then i don't i think like row one like he was
like name name your raccoon name the raccoon yeah guys did
you see the raccoon guys and then the game is going i was
like guys what's holland what's holland doing right now guys
guys let's keep growing
Anyway, thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Ole!
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.